mais cheikh musulman il n'y a rien de
plus important que de parler du combat
pour la cause d'allah si cet imam de
ryad à ses fidèles et le saint combat
auquel il fait référence ce jour là
c'est celui que mène l'arabie saoudite
chez son voisin le yémen nous sommes la
nation à qui le prophète a choisi de
révéler à la musulmans combattez les
infidèles et les hypocrites pour qu'il
brûle en enfer les infidèles en question
ce sont les milices houthistes qui ont
délogé le président du yémen
abed rabbo mansour hadi mais surtout
l'iran qui appuient la milice chiite
cet appel à la ferveur religieuse
rappelle les propos tenus par les
groupes extrémistes comme l'organisation
état islamique où al qaïda et par est
incendiaire dans une région déjà
embrasée par des affrontements sanglants
de nature confessionnelle
le yémen est devenu le plus récent champ
de bataille par procuration entre deux
puissances régionales et demi l'iran
chiite et l'arabie saoudite sunnite et
son gouvernement se défend bien d'en
faire une affaire de religion
depuis qu'il a été chassé par les outils
de la capitale sanaa puis de la ville de
aden dans le sud
le président a dit s'est réfugié à riyad
en arabie saoudite
c'est ici qu'il a plaidé pour une
offensive militaire contre son propre
pays
mais depuis le début de l'opération à
laquelle prennent part 9 armées arabes
on l'a peu revue c'est l'arabie saoudite
qui est à l'avant scène du combat
la campagne militaire de la coalition
saoudienne dont l'objectif avoué est de
rétablir le gouvernement yéménite
chassés du pouvoir par les armes est
très critiqué au yémen mais ici en
arabie saoudite
elle suscite un fort sentiment de fierté
nationaliste coup de main n'allez pas
chercher de voix discordantes ans et sa
longue robe store le cheikh saoud est un
riche entrepreneur avec des entrées
privilégiées auprès de la famille royale
il organise ce genre de rencontre
régulièrement on y discute politique
société religion c'est un sujet d'un
lieu à de vifs débats nous assure-t-on
mais aujourd'hui il est question du
yémen outre s'entendre avec le
conférencier invité
jamal khashoggi lui aussi un proche de
la famille royale sont des arabes
l'arabie saoudite et les arabes se
sentent humiliés par les gestes de l'ira
les iraniens ont une influence une
dominance sans précédent ou juste un peu
ce dont tu resteras un riff claque stade
nous avons assisté à une succession de
réussite en iran que personne n'a su
freiner ou stopper tous les griefs à
l'endroit des iraniens sont nombreux le
maintien de bachar al assad au pouvoir
malgré près de cinq ans de guerre grâce
au soutien de téhéran
l'appui de sa machine de guerre à la
lutte contre le groupe armita islamique
en irak et la signature d'un accord
intérimaire sur le nucléaire avec les
états unis et autres grandes puissances
tout ça au détriment de la population
sunnite dit on nomme maintenant l'arabie
saoudite ce ciel debout pour les
sunnites pour la majorité les jeunes
dans le monde arabe
tout le monde parle de la minorité mais
nous nous défendons la majorité
ici tous se réjouissent de voir l'arabie
saoudite jouer ouvertement son rôle de
puissance régionale
tout le crédit dit on revient au nouveau
roi salman et à son jeune fils le prince
mohamed ministre de la défense
personne ne saurait prédire l'impact de
l'intervention saoudienne ou yémen un
pays qui s'enfonce chaque jour de plus
en plus profondément dans le chaos
mais peu importe les résultats en arabie
saoudite
le nouveau monarque et sa suite ont déjà
remporté une certaine victoire morale
ici marie-eve bédard radio-canada riyad
en arabie saoudite